[Applause]
there was no doubt who they'd come to
see a monarch like no other marking a
moment that britain has never seen
before
had camped out overnight to get a front
row seat for the start of the platinum
jubilee
as the military began their procession
the police were forced to respond
the crowds turning against the animal
rights protesters tried to delay
proceedings
normal service resumed it was time for
the main event the queen's birthday
parade formal and official but at the
heart a family occasion
clear from the very first carriage as
prince george princess charlotte and
prince louis took their first ride down
the mall
their father prince william joined
prince charles and princess anne on
horseback
with the queen unable to travel to watch
the irish guards troop their colour the
trio dispatched to deputize on her
behalf
from the windows of the major general's
office the younger royals watched and
maybe learned
and caught up with those they haven't
seen in a while
it wasn't a secret we knew that megan
and harry were going to be there but
they kept a low profile for the cameras
at buckingham palace the symbol went up
the queen had returned
and then she appeared with her cousin
the duke of kent
in a first for her and for the military
taking the salute from the palace
balcony and casting an expert eye on the
display
as the military returned to barracks and
the crowds were ushered forward you
could see the numbers that had come out
a much needed celebration for many even
during these difficult times and
reaffirmed by this reaction
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
as the queen stepped out with her heirs
and working royals around her
the flypast always a family favorite
prince louis looking less certain at
times
reassured by his great-grandmother
other members of the family not sticking
to the script included prince charles
and camilla walking back to clarence
house
a chance to thank the crowds how was it
you royal highness how was it
quite warm
in another unexpected twist we've now
been told that prince andrew has got
covet we weren't actually expecting to
see him on horse guards for trooping the
color but there are other events
throughout this jubilee where he could
have put in an appearance especially
when the queen has already shown us very
clearly that this is a weekend when she
wants her relatives around her
there was one final duty of the day that
she didn't want to delegate pressing the
button in windsor that would eventually
light up the principal beacon in london
[Music]
[Applause]
overseen by prince william
[Music]
tomorrow her family will again have to
represent her the queen no longer
attending the thanksgiving service at
saint paul's we're told that she has
enjoyed today immensely tomorrow she
needs rest
rhiannon mills sky news at buckingham
palace